hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from this year's
Tata Ste tournament it's a it's a
tournament that's been going on for
almost 100 years uh close to 90 closing
in on 90 has been going on since 1938
and uh well it had different names over
the course of history uh if you remember
from from the year 2000 to year 2010 it
was called the chorus tournament then
from 2011 it was um it became the Tata
steel chess tournament and U it's
incredibly strong it's at the beginning
of the year but already one of the most
awaited tournaments of the year as it
features most often the absolute
strongest players in the world uh and uh
as usual when someone organizes a
tournament it will feature local players
as well so we're going to go into uh
that a little bit later but even though
the highest rated player in the world
Magnus Carlson is not participating this
year it does the tournament does feature
two world champions uh open section
world champion ding Len and women's
world champion Jan Jun and I thought be
a fun to sort of showcase the previous
winners of the tournament ever since it
became the chest tournament so here they
are from 2011 when hikaro Nakamura won
it then in 2012 Leon Aran then Magnus
Carlson in 2013 again in 2014 Leon Aran
then Magnus two years in a row uh then
in 2017 Wesley so then again Magnus
Carlson in 2018 and 2019 then Fabiano
corana in 2020 uh Jordan fforest in 2021
Magnus in 2022 and Anish G
last year in 2023 and now we have 2024
Edition and already uh not all of the
games have finished uh while I'm
recording this but round one was really
action-packed and I'm sure you guys will
have a lot of suggestions uh but I had
to start with one so I decided it to be
this one Local Hero Max vam versus two
times World Championship Challenger
Yanni Pachi uh let's check it out quite
a wild game so uh Max with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to D4 and Max
pretty much uh regardless of whether he
wins or loses uh he always plays an
interesting game I think twice
already uh I chose his game sort of to
be the game of the year uh he always
plays some sort of a brilliant brilliant
Queen sacrifice where he dazzles
everyone and you guys always enjoy those
so very much looking forward to seeing
what what he uh what he's able to do
against the absolute top opposition so
okay D4 Knight to F6 and now Pawn to C4
uh we have Pawn to E6 uh the s sorry not
the Budapest Gambit Pawn to E6 uh Knight
to F3 going for the antmo Indian maybe
asking are you are you interested in
playing a BOGO Indian but noan just
plays Pawn to D5 and he transposes into
the Queen's Gambit decline we have
Knight to C3 D caps on C4 and now Pawn
to E4 the vi variation we have Pawn to
B5 and now advancing the pawn further
with Pawn to E5 Knight to D5 sacrificing
the B5 pawn and Max grabs it so Knight
captur on B5 and now Knight to B6
defending the pawn on C4 uh it's a very
well-known line and many players enjoy
playing it Bishop D2 We have Knight to
C6 now putting more pressure on D4 and
Bishop to E3 we have Bishop to E7 and
now Knight to C Knight back to C3 right
away more popular is Pawn A3 but okay of
course Max had to have something
prepared against nepo we have Bishop to
B7 and now Pawn to A3 and it's a very
nice move as it takes control over the
B4 square but then again it weakens the
B3 Square which means this Knight can
come to B3 uh at its earliest
convenience and there are a couple of
games that reach this position for
example Queen to D7 is a known move but
Yang goes Knight to A5 right away and it
is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how Max
continues here we have Queen to C2 now
comes Queen to D7 nepo hinting at maybe
castling Queen side although yeah we
still don't know but it it is um the
most probable
uh solution as you do have the queen
here you'd have the possibility of the
Knight coming to G5 maybe some H4 action
so castling Queen side is the way to go
uh Rook to D1 aligning The Rook nicely
with the queen Here and Now Pawn to F5
by neppo and uh that's the thing by uh
offering uh your opponent to capture
alasan uh it's possible to only do it on
the Move where it's possible so he
captures an F6 is possible now but never
again after this move has been made
eight so unless you do it this Pawn will
remain on F5 so of course it's best to
do it e captures on F6 uh G captures and
now Knight to E4 uh we have Queen to A4
and this always uh uh I like to mention
that it reminds me of the old Josh
waitzkin saying that uh be careful of
the square Left Behind or you always
have to be mindful of the square Left
Behind when the Knight was on C3 it had
control over the A4 square but now even
though you've improved or sort of
improved the position of your knight uh
you've so you've kind of lost control
over the A4 square and nepo immediately
takes advantage of that Queen to A4 and
the queen trade might not be terrible uh
you know in uh particular situations but
here it would be kind of bad because now
the Knight on e4 would be undefended and
the pawn on B2 would be undefended so
instead after this queen to A4 move we
have Queen back to B1 and now nippo
castles Queen side uh Knight to C5
attacking the queen and the bishop so
you will either win this bishop or this
bishop and nepo decides to trade on C5
Bishop captures on C5 D captures and now
Knight to D5 putting more pressure on
that Bishop here and here Max finally
decided to Castle regardless of whether
he castles or not Neo's Next plan is to
go put put Rooks on the G file and go
after that King
side uh so max does Castle King side and
now Rook D to G8 and here sort of why I
named the the title ghost of Tata Steel
as I'm sure we'll see many more uh when
you have a situation like this okay you
have Castle King side you have your
opponent's Rook on G8 on a nice semiopen
G file uh you have this bishop
controlling this diagonal you know that
those Knights will move at some point
the the G2 Pawn will become uh very weak
uh but uh defending prematurely in chess
is a a well sort of a recipe for
disaster here you you you have to play
something like Queen to E4 uh or Rook to
D4 and then okay que Queen to E4 does
look really weird because the Knight is
here but there is no uh great Square for
the Knight and also you're just
threatening Queen captures on E6 which
will come with Tempo so you don't really
have to worry about this queen to E4 is
a beautiful centralizing move uh however
Max played Pawn to G3 sort of to get rid
of this idea of Rook or bishop ever
capturing on G2 uh but by playing this
he also created a Target that nepo is
able to hone in on and he immediately
does Pawn to H5 and now uh H4 is coming
and there's no good way to handle that
if you play H4 then you weaken the G3
pawn and then just for example capis
capis and rook capis and G3 uh will be
huge problem for white and this will be
winning for black so instead after Pawn
to
H5 uh we have Rook to D4 uh trying to
stop Pawn to H4 this way but now Queen
to C6 even more problems arise by
opening up this diagonal and by playing
this G3 move so okay uh again H4 has to
be stopped somehow uh we have Knight to
sorry Rook to H4 uh but now Knight
captures on E3 and while Knight captures
on E3 is a wonderful move by neppo I
just want to show you a line that uh is
even Superior to Jan's line but only
maybe in um in in well style points so I
don't know I I want to show it to you
Rook to G4 and what do you play now uh
okay Rook captures on G4 H captures you
attack the Knight and the Knight moves
Knight to D4 attacks the queen so you
don't give black time to move the Knight
and Checkmate the black king and now
look at this Knight to F4 uh the black
queen is threatening Checkmate while
also offering the queen and there's no
other move you have to play Knight
captures on C6 now comes Knight captures
on E2 with check King to G2 and now not
Bishop captures with check that would
allow F3 but first Knight captures on F6
uh because the Knight needs to come to
E5 in order for the position to be
winning and now after Pawn to F3 of
course you want to stop any checks here
Knight to E5 going um uh for that F3
Pawn with a triple attack and there's
really nothing white can do here after
let's say Bishop G1 you will capture on
F3 with check King to F2 and now Pawn to
F5 and that's pretty much it the Knight
can come to G4 with check to D3 with
check and the the white king just gets
destroyed here there's really there's
really nothing for for white to do here
so well it is a incredibly impressive
Yan goes for a less forcing line he
plays Knight captures on E3 right away F
captures and now Rook to G4 so not
starting with Rook to G4 right away uh
but now Queen to C1 uh just getting the
queen to help out with the defense but
now the of course what was planned Rook
captures on H4 point being that the
Knight on F3 cannot move as you're going
to get checkmated here so G captures and
H4 has to be played and now just Knight
to B3 nippo brings more pieces into the
attack we have Queen to C3 now comes
Knight captures on C5 collecting
material as of course your position is
completely winning uh Queen captures on
F6 was played now Rook to G8 with check
if you go to F2 then of course Knight E4
check picks up the queen so you can do
that King to H1 was played and now Queen
to E4 again just playing solid moves not
much for for Max to do here Rook to G1
was played and nepo just removed the The
Rook from the G5 played Rook to d8 and
he was in this position un move 29 that
Max vadam resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh his uh
his position is terrible there's nothing
he can do against this beautiful queen
Bishop battery along this diagonal and
uh even if you somehow kill the attack
even if you trade Queens off let's say
with Queen to F4 uh Yan will happily do
it he will trade queens and just play
Rook D2 and it's game over the Knight
cannot move the bishop will fall next uh
there's no square for the bishop uh if
if if you move the bishop then again you
lose the Knight and if you defend the
bishop uh then it's a matter of simple
Rook captures on E2 and after Rook
captures Bishop captures an F3 with
check okay you can block check with the
Rook but after captures captures it's
Knight against uh you know poor King and
those pawns and even Knight E3 will
eliminate the B Pawn create a pass C
pawn and that's it so doesn't really
require any um uh attention or or even
maybe you know considering to to to play
this position
so yeah Max resigned nothing to do here
and a wonderful start for Yan in this
tournament a win with the black pieces
against a very strong local player and
uh yeah this is the game I I chose as
usual yam plays very interesting chess
very active chess Max also always plays
very interesting very active chess and
this is the result uh okay maybe NEPA
could have chosen that crazy line that
I've shown uh but no no reason to you
know sacrifice your queen um it's a clal
game and a really big tournament and if
you if you can't really see Checkmate or
see that you will be able to uh to you
know fully fully uh commit to this or
maybe you know completely immobilize
your opponent uh Yan's Choice was
definitely the the better option uh but
yeah very nicely done by Yan and even
though that game against women's world
champion je engine and Anish giri was
still happening when I started recording
this and uh they started playing at 1:
p.m. uh Central European Time and the
game was still going on at 8 8 8:00 p.m.
Central European Time so the game lasted
well over 7 hours I will now check uh
what happened in the game so for those
of you who are not interested in results
of other games uh don't watch the video
anymore but I will check it out now so
uh yeah way defeated donchenko ala fuja
defeated Jan van Forest ding Len and
vidit drer game J and Jun lost Anish
giri but I did watch the game a little
bit and uh yeah it was a pretty crazy
game jenin was better in some positions
then Anish was better then it was a draw
all in all crazy game where Anish was
able to really grind out the full point
uh gkes and Abdus satov featured a
beautiful queen sacrifice uh but I will
not tell you how their game Ended as I
might show it so I don't want to spoil
it too much uh you've seen the game
neppo versus max neppa won a very nice
game and prananda versus makulu ended in
a draw so those are the results of round
one uh so
you know full point to to nepo Ala Anish
and way half a point to everyone else
and zero point for the moment Yan pz
donchenko Max vam and the je Eng so if
you have any any of your favorites do
use hasht suggestion also I'm mostly
going to cover the master section but
you have if you have any nice games from
The Challengers Edition uh also use
hashtag suggestion and I will definitely
uh look into it uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it sorry
about my voice being a little little
weird um no idea what's happening but
you know it is as it is I do have a I do
have a 2-year-old daughter and uh she
constantly brings new you know new
viruses from the kindergarten so what
are you going to do uh I would like to
thank Welsh fan Sasha vidler Mark Henley
Brennan Michael males and Frank Banner
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions but mostly
covering the Tata steel until it
finishes and it finishes on the 28th of
January at least I think it does uh let
me just check yep 28th of January see
you
soon